one thousand pound sister star Tammy
Slayton is showing off her dramatic
weight loss this is gonna help
me in the long run earlier this week the
reality star shared that these snaps to
Instagram showing off her slim down
physique and fans sprinted to the
comments of the caption-free post to
show their love one writing I think I
speak for everyone when I say we are so
proud of you another adding gotta admit
Tammy you proved a whole lot of us wrong
way to go and keep it up while another
fan noted that Tammy no longer had the
tracheal tube she had been using to help
her breathe after I woke up the Eggman
he mentioned that Jake they you know
told me it was reassured that I had a
clear water into my lungs if something
else happened my worst fears not being
able to breathe the post was Tammy's
first since February 14th prior to that
she hadn't posted since March 2022. and
I got on a scale and seen the scale was
at 5 34.7 I kind of stopped breathing
for a second I'm like 14 pounds under my
goal weight from over 700. that's
my huge shot Tammy's weight loss Journey
has been documented on the latest season
of the reality show including the moment
she hit a major weight loss goal that
qualified her for weight loss surgery
dropping from 717 pounds to
534 pounds
I'm feeling thrilled proud
decided
all the emotions
my birthday right wrong
everybody doubted me
I finally got myself
this old woman and while her new pics
shows she's lost even more weight than
what viewers have seen on TV it's not
yet confirmed whether she had the
procedure but during an episode that
aired last month Tammy was greeted and
celebrated by her whole family as she
leaves an Ohio rehab facility to undergo
the weight loss operation I needed to
know that they're here for me they love
me
that's one of my
biggest jobs
the biggest thing to help push me
through
to get to where I am now meanwhile
Tammy's sister Amy is nervous about her
sister going under the knife
anything can happen during surgery
like I couldn't picture a life without
my sister well seems like Tammy's doing
great and making progress in her health
Journey
[Music]